hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to share with you how to
heal your acne I wish I would have known
this when I was going through high
school I had really bad skin so I'm
going to share with you what to do
there's several factors that will affect
the skin but primarily we're going to
talk about the anatomy of something
called a sebaceous gland what is a
sebaceous gland it's a little gland on
in your skin you have that in your hair
you have them all over the place but you
don't have them over the soles of your
feet in different places but basically
if this clan is now functioning you will
have acne blackheads whiteheads oily
skin dry skin you can have any
combination and so let's start with the
vitamin A if your vitamin A is low
you're going to have problems with this
gland vitamin A controls and regulates
this gland in your skin so without
vitamin A your skin can be really really
bad there's a couple factors you need to
know though about what what happens at
the cellular level vitamin A can kill
unfriendly bacteria in your skin and so
one of the myths that people have is
that they think they have to just scrub
out these blackheads and whiteheads and
scrub their face and sterilize your face
that's going to damage your skin that's
what I used to do and it was incorrect
because you have a layer of friendly
bacteria on your skin that's supposed to
be there to protect you
when you scrub too hard you can destroy
that also when you take antibiotics you
will destroy it as well so I know people
take antibiotics and their skin gets
better but if you can just keep your
good bacteria in your gut healthy you
don't have to go that route there's even
a condition I mean a drug called
accutane which is a high level of
vitamin synthetic vitamin A which was
really good for the skin but it has a
lot of side effects so anytime you take
a vitamin in high potencies it comes
with a package there's a lot of problems
we don't want to do that we want to take
vitamin A typically in its natural form
not synthetic okay I'll show you how to
what to do so but vitamin
it can control the bacterial growth
controls the oil coming of the skin the
dryness and actually it can get rid of
acne vitamin A foods you know people
think of carrots spinach kale anything
orange or yellow that's true but those
vitamins in the vegetable family are pre
vitamin A factors they're not active
forms so your body has to convert the
pre vitamin A to the active form and
it's very difficult for you to but your
body to do that in many cases if you're
lucky you might convert four to five
percent so you're really not getting
your vitamin A source from the vegetable
you're getting it from the animal
products that you eat and that's why a
vegetarian has a lot of dry skin
they have vitamin A deficiencies which
is dry eyes can't see at night sinus
problems things like that so the best
source of vitamin A that I would
recommend a natural source would be cod
liver oil but not just any kind of oil
you want to get a colorful oil that is
virgin cod liver oil because when you
get traditional inexpensive cheap cod
liver oil you're basically getting a lot
of problems you're getting added
vitamins you're getting a heated product
that kills off all the good nutrition
it's refined it might have too much of
one thing versus the other I don't like
it so there's a lot of problems with
just real cheap cholera I would get a
high quality virgin cod liver oil and
also as a side note you probably have
heard about the fermented cod liver oil
right now I used to buy into that but as
I was studying it I realized you can't
ferment cod liver oil
you can't ferment an oil only a
carbohydrate so basically it's bogus and
when I bought this stuff it tastes very
very fishy because it's when you try to
ferment it you're going to cause rancidity or a souring effect and it's
going to go rancid so the cod liver oil if it's fresh shouldn't shouldn't have a
bad smell but that's a really good
source of not just vitamin A but vitamin
D as well which we'll get to
also liver personally I don't like
eating liver but I just want you know
that liver has a lot about of an A but
of course if you're going to do liver do
grass-fed organic don't do just regular
liver and then the other thing is butter
Kerrygold butter is a really good source
of grass-fed butter and that has its
load with vitamin A that would be a good
source of vitamin A and egg yolks
pasture-raised egg yolks that's what I
would recommend I have a lot of those
that's really loaded with vitamin A so
vitamin A is very important and
regulating the sebaceous gland and
that's the first thing you need to do I
don't recommend doing massively high
potency just fractionated vitamin A
pills because there's a toxicity problem
with that you're going to create
deficiencies and other things okay you
have to really know what you're doing
now next thing is low vitamin D vitamin
D is not just for your bones it's not
just for your mood it's for your skin
and guess where you get this from the
Sun and guess you also can get it from
the cod liver oil so cod liver oil has a
nice balance of vitamin D and vitamin A but
Sun and despite what you've been taught
about Sun Sun is actually very very
healthy for the skin and it doesn't
cause skin cancer
no in fact Sun actually protects you
against a lot of types of skin cancer
and other cancers because the vitamin D
actually is good for the immune system
now I'm not saying lay out in the Sun
and get completely leathered and like
burnt things like that I'm just talking
about a little bit of Sun is really good
for the sin skin so but these two are
really important and vitamin all the fat
soluble vitamins vitamin A D K there's
something unique about them they have
the ability to be stored in fat and also
they have the ability to go through the
fat layer of the cell and into the
center of the cell where the DNA is and
they can affect the DNA of the cell and
control your genes and that's why if
you're deficient in these fats either
vitamins you can have a lot of
structural problems with your proteins
your
body tissues okay so that's a little bit
different than the other water soluble
vitamins like vitamin B things like that
so vitamin D vitamin A very important
gallbladder I want to mention that
because if a person has a congested
gallbladder or a congested liver or a
bad liver or no gallbladder what's going
to happen is that you're not going to
have enough bile B I L E bile is a fluid
that kind of helps you break down fats
and fat soluble vitamins so if you're
consuming these and your skin is not
getting better it could be that you just
don't have enough support from the
gallbladder to absorb them into the body
so it's just something I always look at
when someone's taking these things
because you need to be able to not just
get it but absorb it okay next thing
androgens
what is an androgen an androgen is a
hormone produced by your stress gland
your adrenal glands on top of your
kidney but it's also produced by the
ovary okay and the testicle but mainly
this in a female is coming out of the
ovary and that during that time of the
month they might have a little acne
because they have a their ratio they
have a little too much energy in versus
estrogen so if that happens they'll get
acne I have videos and how to deal with
that but guess what triggers androgens
sugar yeah too much sugar so if you were
to have a problem with androgens or other
conditions called polycystic ovarian
syndrome if you don't know what that is
that's fine but if you if you have it
you know what I'm talking about
the best solution for that is to get the
sugar down to zero in your diet okay and
that will help you greatly so there's
two things that will increase androgens
one is sugar and the other thing is
stress okay so sugar and stress really
affect your your skin then we have
vitamin b5 what does b5 pantothenic acid
panasonic acid is a vitamin that has
that gives you nice clear skin the
problem is people take it synthetically
or they take too much of it individually
and then they create deficiencies and
other things like biotin and their hair
starts getting brittle so again I'm not
saying go out there and start taking
massive dosages just realize that
vitamin b5 does control the skin and you
just need to look at what depletes
vitamin b5 and that would be stress so
again stress is a factor that we want to
start to deal with and lower that to
help your skin the other thing is
insulin insulin is a hormone that
regulates blood sugars and insulin is
triggered by sugar so and that's also in
the hidden sugars like breads pasta
cereal crackers viscous waffles pancakes
muffins sodas juice alcohol all that
will influence this gland right here now
these are really comprehensive things
but if you have acne you need things
that you can do to better your skin and
not be stuck in a situation where you're
taking accutane or some antibiotics so
you want to be able to look at all these
to see maybe what's missing in your diet
if you're a junk food junkie like I was
then you need to start consuming these
foods and get the sugar out of the diet
your skin will clear up nicely the other
thing that I'm going to recommend is
that even no vegetables don't have the
active form of vitamin A you're going to
have to eat a large quantities to get
all the other nutrients the minerals the
other vitamins that make these work and
then clean out your liver because you
can't just you know live on cod liver oil
you know so I highly recommend you eat
the vegetables as well the combination
of that with some of these things
cutting the sugar out trying to avoid
the stress as much as possible that can
greatly improve your skin so go ahead
and do these things and then write your
comments below